if you could describe yourself in three
words
what would you use i would say dizzy
[ __ ] rascal
cheers
yo what's going on today i'm doing
talking to myself with unilad
and my guest is dizzy raw school what's
going
on what's happening brother you good
absolutely
what are you doing how am i i'm a bit
tired to be honest man
i'm tired as well you know tired of your
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you too let's just get this over
and done with him
what is your earliest memory of
performing my earliest memory of
performing would have been i think in
primary school me and my friend
he did beatbox and i kind of rapped
along to it in the classroom we must
have been like yeah
you're free or something like that
[Music]
did the crowd go wild no
anyway out of all the tracks that you
have made which is your favorite
and why now of all the tracks i made
what is my favorite and why
um if i base it on
reaction or what what is like the
biggest moment whenever i play it's
probably bonkers
everywhere a guy around the world is
just it's like
everywhere just feels like wembley
stadium when i played that tune it's
like that's like the commercial stuff in
it that's the merch team
there's others that maybe i prefer that
i enjoy more that maybe i made
like stop that or or i love you and
things like that but
now you're live not through
what is your biggest pet peeve nothing
no
not grounds my gears people pressing me
to answer questions i don't want to
answer
[ __ ] wrong with me
you got a bit of attitude
what about slow walkers you like slow
walkers there's nothing wrong with a
slow walk
it's a good slow walk in the morning let
you know where you are in life man
if you could describe yourself in three
words
what would you use i would say dizzy
[ __ ] rascal
cheers so
what is the first big purchase you made
the
the first big purchase i made that's a
good question i don't know
i don't know remember [ __ ] i'll
come back to that one
what is your biggest guilty pleasure my
biggest guilty pleasure
when i put on the spot for these
questions there are
my biggest pleasure selling sunset on
netflix
that's my biggest guilty pleasure
because i just i really like looking at
them
they're nice houses nice houses yeah
should we get one i like looking at them
i like looking at them i think they're
overpriced personally
what is your creative process of writing
lyrics listen to the beat
and trying to kind of obviously vibrate
and then kind of try and
find space in the gaps that's how i
usually just try and find out am i going
to follow the drums or am i going to
follow the melody
do you write lyrics on the go if i'm
sitting down to write a song i usually
just sit down to write it
even if i get one verse i write another
verse later
get the thing done there and then in it
obviously we spent a lot of time
together during lockdown
what did you learn about us what do we
learn about each other we learned that
we're a great company
we're we're just all around i agree yeah
we've gotten all right man i feel like
i think yeah we've gotten great i'm i'm
i'm
i'm great are you all right as well
what has been your career highlight so
far hmm
career highlight so far oh mate that's a
good one
i don't know let me leave that one to
you what are you saying
oh yeah i went platinum independently
i've been platinum twice got my first
album
and my fourth album um
done the olympics took care of the
family i've done a bunch of stuff man
done a bunch of stuff yeah that's good
that's good i could think of a few
others
better than that but
i mean i'm trying to be humble here man
be humble fam have you had a nice time
yeah man of course i've got here to talk
to myself and talk about myself spin all
right yeah
honestly who do you think would win the
fight between you
me obviously i reckon it will be a bit
even still
nah man
you